C
Mas okay so I'm going to teach you
hopefully
tonight some small pieces if the cameras
get it then you'll have something to
refer back to let's start off with
um let's start off with uh the
etiquette just stand a bit there okay
there the etiquette I'm I've got my Ken
and you always have it here because uh
they only have
right-handed uh Samurai they they they
they tied the hand behind their back as
they were growing up left-handed all
right so so it's in my left I've just
done let's say I'm attacking him or
whatever and we're going to exchange the
my Ken and he's going to then have a try
so I will offer it like this with the
blade to me and the handles to his right
so I'm putting my trust in him so I do
this and I don't do this I don't stick
my butt out okay I just bow he puts his
hands in the middle like this of mine
and straight away rolls it back so he he
takes on so so he's going to be offering
it to me with the blade towards you or
else that's very
rude I put my hands in the middle so
what I do is I'll show you I just I roll
it as I bow so so I don't bow and then
roll it I take it
again okay so
I all right so it's before my head comes
up I've got it again so thank you the
whole point of
um the weapon is it's a piece of wood
you know that's all it is if you want to
think of it as a sword and you know
become a little samai and start thinking
that you're cutting through things
that's okay that means that we haven't
grown up
yet but but it's a wooden sword it's a
piece of wood so it's to help the body
movement so in the
end um your your toe down there and your
hands or your thought
should turn together so if if I turn the
Ken and nothing happens down there it
means that this is mechanical and I'm
having to do it with my mental if I do
that I've been doing it long enough
that it just automatically works right
so you're trying to do the weapons to
improve your body techniques your tets
you're not doing it um to go out there
and pretend you're you know some sort of
samai against another
Sam right
so so so um that's what you're working
to